hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 27 hört zu und spricht nach
michael sagt dass er krank ist
michael sagt dass er hunger hat michael
sagt dass er hunger hat michael sagt
dass er sich schlecht fühlt michael
dass er sich schlecht fühlt
der arzt
sagt dass sich gesünder essen soll der a
sagt dass ich gesünder essen soll der
arzt
sagt dass ich nicht rauchen soll der
arzt sagt dass ich nicht rauchen soll
der arzt sagt dass ich mehr sport
treiben soll
treiben soll die mutter ruft den arzt an
die mutter ruft den arzt an die mutter
misst das fieber die mutter misst das
fieber die mutter weckt das kind die
mutter weckt das kind der arzt
untersucht den patienten der arzt
untersucht den patienten der arzt gibt
mir ein medikament der arzt gibt mir ein
medikament der
wäscht sich die hände der arzt wäscht
sich die hände
ich habe fieber ich habe fieber
ich habe kopfschmerzen
mein kopf tut weh mein kopf
es tut weh
mein bauch tut weh mein bauch tut weh
ich habe
merzen ich habe bauchschmerzen
meine ohren tun weh meine ohren tun weh
ich habe ohren
merzen ich habe ohrenschmerzen
ich bin erkältet
ich habe husten
ich nehme
kamenz ich nehme
ein medikament
mai
gebrochen mein bein ist gebrochen
mein arm ist verstaucht
er trägt einen schal um den hals
er trägt einen verband um den kopf
das auto fährt durch den tunnel
wir atmen durch die nase
das medikament ist gegen das fieber das
medikament ist gegen das fieber die
tabletten sind gegen die schmerzen
die tabletten sind gegen die schmerzen
du hast schöne augen
[Musik]
du hast schöne haare
du hast schöne beine
du hast
schöne zähne du hast schöne zähne
du hast schöne finger du hast schöne
finger du hast eine gute figur
du hast eine gute figur
das bein die beine das bein die beine
das auge die augen das auge die augen
das ohr die ohren das ohr die ohren der
zahn die zähne der zahn die zähne der
arm die arme der arm
die arme
der finger die finger der finger die
finger
die schulter die schultern
die schulter die schulter
die
die nasen
die nasen die diagnose die diagnosen die
diagnose die diagnosen